well Intermountain Health the sponsors
of this segment want to remind you about
the risk factors of high blood pressure
here's what you need to know
welcome to the Intermountain My
Generation Maryland Parkway clinic and
we're going to be talking about high
blood pressure and why it's so important
most people don't know they have high
blood pressure until they come to the
medical office there are things that you
cannot control your genetics your family
history
um but there are many things that we can
control to help modify our blood
pressure one thing I always tell
patients is you don't have to add salt
to your food in the United States we use
so many preservatives in our food the
main one being salt you actually don't
have to add additional salt to your food
and that's one way to lower your blood
pressure another one is how much are you
smoking how much are you smoking can you
reduce your cigarette intake a day that
will help with blood pressure how much
are you actually drinking in terms of
alcohol are you mixing both wine beer
and hard Spirits can we reduce the
amount of alcohol that we're drinking in
a day or how are you moving are you
moving at all how about let's walk 30
minutes a day with a friend that can
help reduce high blood pressure while
the number
um decrease is not important the fact
that it will decrease in general is what
will happen after Maryland Parkway My
Generation senior Clinic to manage my
patience high blood pressure I often
tell them to come in for regular blood
pressure checks we can do this as often
as every two weeks to see if the
medications are actively effective in
working we often do medication reviews
are you actually taking the medication
the way that it's supposed to be taken
on a daily basis we also talk about
dietary changes that can be made in
addition we have Intermountain Health
classes where patients can actually
learn about a hypertension diet patients
are often asking you Dr Bradley what gym
should I go to and I tell my patients
you don't have to go to the gym to lower
your blood pressure something as simple
as walking 30 minutes a day with a goal
of losing even two pounds a week can
lower patient's blood pressure between
five to ten points easily and so I tell
patients that the goal is how often
they're using their physical activity
not necessarily the number of days that
they're doing it how often are you
actually getting to 30 minutes I'm a
good physical activity will help lower
your blood pressure I often talk to my
patients about a dash diet I'm going to
say Dr Bradley what is a dash diet what
does dash mean to dietary approach to
hypertension to decrease the things that
we're getting in our diet eating more
vegetables again not adding any salt to
the foods that you're already eating
decreasing our caffeine intake patients
often say I'm not doing anything to
increase the my blood pressure but
they're drinking three cups of coffee a
day coffee canning preacher to increase
your blood pressure significantly one of
the things that I often discuss with
patients is taking time for themselves
focusing on what it actually is that
they need focusing on self-care is
essential to decreasing one's blood
pressure and finding things that you
like to do that are enjoyable often when
you're having fun your blood pressure is
at a lower level so it's important to
increase one's self-care in terms of
blood pressure
[Music]
thank you to Intermountain Health for
sponsoring this segment for more
information you can head to
intermountainnv.org Las Vegas now we'll
be right back